so the start of this spring offensive
even though as Sean was saying it's not
yet spring
well yes you can probably see behind me
it's very wintry not spring at all but I
think
it's interesting and important thing to
come out today from the head of NATO was
that very clear warning that he made to
Western allies about this race for
Logistics that is really on right now
basically underlining the fact that
whoever is able to make weapons fastest
and whoever is able to supply ammunition
fastest will have the edge in this war
and will most likely win and Yen
sultanburg was really underlining the
challenge that's facing Western allies
now allies that since the end of the
Cold War have massively reduced their
capacity to produce weapons at speed and
scale the scale that's needed for the
Ukrainian military right now given the
amount of ammunition they're having to
use against Russia Russia has its own
problems with its Logistics and supply
chain it's under heavy sanctions but it
has a huge industrial base the the
president is trying to put his economy
more and more onto a war footing it
means that factories are being cranked
into military production from civilian
production it's the kind of thing that
really needs to start happening fast
across the UK for example and other
European nations the head of NATO
singled out the US and France saying
they were among the Allies that have
started to take this genuinely seriously
but to give you a sense of the challenge
he said that because the demand is so
great and the supply is so small it's
actually taking longer and longer now to
produce and receive these weapons if you
put an order in now for a large caliber
missile it's not going to erupt to
arrive for two and a half years and that
compares with 12 months before The
Invasion which was already a long time
it's a big challenge he's clearly alive
to it you've got defense ministers
meeting in at NATO headquarters this
week for a couple of days there's also a
big security conference happening later
in the week in Germany and absolutely
Ukraine and this support for Ukraine is
going to be at the heart of that and
Logistics really count they might sound
boring but they really matter